pas de rap aujourd'hui pour joey starr
mais du théâtre avec son spectacle
éloquence à l'assemblée avec notamment
deux grandes figures historiques
robespierre à lamartine victor hugo
pourquoi ces grandes figures de
l'histoire
pourquoi non c'est surtout le choc
important déjà passé pas juste les
figures et puis c'est surtout en fait
quelque chose qui m'a été proposée par
pierre grillet et jérémie lippmann et au
départ pierre grillet revisitait puis
ces grands hommes qui ont été et qui ont
fait autorité qui ont fait de la
politique et qui aussi on est artiste me
côté donc voilà il a eu l'idée c'était
un peu plus d'un nom de m dames avec l
richard mille madame mettra en scène et
me proposer et c'est important que les
discours sortent des bâtiments
institutionnels
mais bien sûr que c'est toujours
important comme en forêt puis dans les
tons dans le théâtre il ya même des gens
qui se déplacent y sont passés n'ont pas
forcément au théâtre parce que c'est moi
et autres donc bien sûr c'est important
ça ça arrive à cusco c'est l'un des
objectifs d'un de la pièce moi j'ai déjà
dit tout ce que je fais je le fais pour
moi je le fais pour moi principalement
et parce que ça m'intéresse c'est parce
que voilà après ces gens convergent
dessus c'est génial mais on part je ne
pense pas ce genre de choses quoi savez
vous ce qui est triste c'est que c'est
sur le peuple
que pèse la peine de mort vous avez
obligé dites vous il a appelé dans un
plateau de la balance ignorance et la
misère
il fallait un contrepoids dans l'autre
plateau vous y avez mis la peine de mort
est bien ôter la peine de mort vous va
la forcer forcé entendez-vous de thé
aussi les nuances et la misère nous est
condamné à toutes ces améliorations à la
fois alors le théâtre montansier a été
créé en 1777
est ce que le discours à plus de
résonance ici dans un lieu historique
comme celui là oui son nom voir si on
veut quoi mais pour moi
que ce soit que j'ai le jouer à anjou ou
hameaux ou et voilà maintenant après
effectivement c'est le premier théâtre
c'est surtout pour moi c'est bon je
trouve que c'est surtout mon ego que ça
flatte puis voilà quoi mais après pas
prêt comme je le disais moi ce qu'il
nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est que
tout ça tout ça soit porté le de manière
avec justesse je veux dire mais c'est
une première ici pour vous avez recel
c'est le première pour moi à versailles
et du coup quel est le discours que vous
avez le plus aimé ça se ferment à
l'humeur ça change bien sûr j'ai une
version de présentation ouais ouais ça
ce pas l'humeur mais c'est sûr que j'ai
une affection particulière pour pour
aimé césaire par exemple voilà mais
sinon non faut savoir que pour certains
discours comme monsieur d'idéologues de
gauche qu'elle n'a pas pu livrer ou
robespierre ou je reste les chansons
mort le lendemain voire quelques jours
après quoi donc on sent que déjà on est
plus on n'est pas dans la dynamique
d'aujourd'hui où on a des énarques qui
sont ou des politiciens qui sont des
managers et le privé a pris le pas sur
public d'endettement alors que on sent
qu'il ya des relents de ça déjà c'est
époque à 1700 autres mais on sent qu'il
ya plus de militantisme plus de ventre
plus de coeur enfin voilà quoi
mais comment fait on se met dans la peau
de ses personnages ses personnages déjà
comme je le disais au départ on peut on
peut c'est déjà comme je le disais au
départ ce sont des gens décédés gens qui
concourent écrit pour le théâtre conte
écrit tout court voilà donc donc on sent
que dans l'écriture et que des très
théâtral même si ça reste de la
politique même s'ils sont là pour
informer annoncé imposer aux autres
il ya quelque chose de ya quelque chose
de très théâtral déjà donc de fait à
part robespierre qui est avocat voilà
tous les autres donc du coup
du coup ça du coup c'est écrit avec avec
une certaine
verve en phase enfin voilà quoi donc
donc c'est ce qui me permet peut-être de
trouver une porte pour pouvoir y accéder
il ya un jour dans l'année où le plus
imperceptibles citoyen où l'attendent
social participe à la vie heymans du
pays tout entier ou la buse et 3
poitrine se dilate allaire vaste des
affaires publiques
un jour le plus faible sens en lui la
grandeur de la souveraineté nationale
et qu'est ce qu'elle est le camp selon
vous c'est le corps la voix les deux à
la fois les silences la posture c'est
plein de choses c'est plein de
paramètres le corps en six jours
oui je vais je vous ai joué et est ce
que la mise en scène vous êtes tout seul
du coup sur scène est ce que ça apporte
un autre aura encore plus bas
heureusement sinon ça serait inutile je
dors devant le théâtre est pas dans le
théâtre
oui non mais tout à fait la misère c'est
un autre pour le coup est très moderne
très simple très sobre c'est ce que
j'aime et bien sûr que l amène à morges
et st géry jouer dans la dans la salle
des pas perdus à la gare saint lazare et
plein de lumière machin vers 18 heures
bon voilà je me sens un peu amoindri
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas la mise en
scène et je pense que même pour les gens
qui rentraient chez eux comme ça voilà
le truc était là parce que les gens
étaient curieux à propos du mieux que je
pouvais outre la voilà mais je sais que
si on avait pu avoir des rideaux machin
enfin tout le truc la mise en scène je
sais que cela rapporte il ya un dialogue
direct aussi avec le public vous le
public
ça vous va bien ça parle forcément
d'éloquence votre votre spectacle
est-ce que l'éloquence pour vous qu'est
ce que ça représente qu'est ce que ça
représente 16 ans éloquence je pense
qu'on a manqué ce qu'est ce qu'il y as
qu'il y en ait des mots sur lesquels je
sais pas où vous avez insisté peut-être
dans votre spectacle
y'a pas de mots sur les 4,6 il ya je
pense que tout était plus de dahmane est
enfin possible de la manière dont ça a
été livré par les auteurs
l'éloquence et là c'est la manière de
livrer comme jette à leur coûter dans
les silences la posture c'est
l'intention quoi l'éloquence et
l'intention tout court quoi c'est
l'intention c'est pour moi leo quand
c'est aussi la vie dans le dans
l'échangé enfin voilà dans la question
qu'est ce que vous aimeriez que les gens
retiennent un centime spectacle y en a
16 ans issus jeu j'ai pas de gpg pas de
vérité ou de volonté propre qu'ils
soient qui se sait pas ce que les gens
retiennent c'est je voudrais 7 les gens
on va dire pour ceux qui une bombe au
théâtre et sont là les curieux peuvent
peut-être ouais si ça peut réveiller une
une certaine conscience citoyenne qui
sommeille en eux ouais ça peut être ça
peut être bien
sinon on voit bien ça prenne enfin parce
que je laisse chacun libre cours à sa
perception de quoi voilà mon cal
beaucoup merci